hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice bullet game between andrew tang and
magnus carlson a lot of you guys have
requested that for me to show at least
one game from the match and i don't know
how many games exactly the match was but
magnus was winning uh some games and
then uh one game ended in a draw then
magnus again was winning some games and
then uh andrew won a game and after this
uh win magnus just got 10 straight wins
in a row uh and in chess this is called
adoption
so
when you you know completely obliterate
your opponent without allowing him to
draw or win a single game uh i'm not
sure where the coin uh where the term
was coined but if you guys have any uh
insight into that to do share so we can
all expand our vast knowledge uh i've
heard there are terms like double
adoption triple adoption you know uh
depending on how much you can uh you
know destroy your opponent uh but this
is one game i've chosen it's uh remember
it's a bullet game so of course the
moves uh played are not uh you know
the absolute best but it will give you
an idea especially if you're a beginner
on how things can go really really wrong
if you give one of the players just one
one tempo in the opening so that being
said let's check it out uh and see uh
how the game wins so andrew with the
white pieces opens with d4 we have d5 by
magnus knight to f3 and the c5 now we
are going for the cross variation we
have c4 by andrew and now c captures on
d4 we have queen captures on d4 uh sorry
about that
and this is nothing uh out of the
ordinary this can be played in knight to
f6 and now uh it's very important to
capture this pawn on d5 and after this
we just go into this for example
captures captures we attack the black
queen we can trade here captures
captures a6 and that's it then the game
continues however in the game andrew
played knight to c3 probably pre-moved
it doesn't really matter as
i said that we uh
we're showing this just to show how how
uh you know terribly wrong things can go
if you give um black in this example one
very important tempo so here uh knight
to c6 by magnus attacking the queen now
you have to move the queen we have queen
back hold all the way to d1 you could go
to f4 you could go maybe to d3 but as
this is bullet you want your queen as
far away from your opponent's pieces as
possible so d4 attacking the knight now
and now if you go knight d5 then we're
just going to capture it and then win
the pawn as well so andrew goes back
knights to b1 and now e5 so
defending that d for pawn but also
preparing to develop the bishop here so
we have e3 challenging this advanced
pawn and now bishop to be for check by
magnus so you could block with the
knight then we're just going to capture
an e3 so he blocks with the bishop but
it doesn't help all that much magnus
just captures an e3 and now of course
the bishop can't be captured if you
capture the bishop we're first gonna
throw in this situation with uh e
captures an f2 with check and after king
captures we're gonna pick up the queen
so the king of course cannot capture you
would have to play king e2 but then
queen captures on d1 king captures
knight captures on b4 and this is now
completely unplayable uh e4 is coming e3
is coming and there's not much you can
play here of course if you if you go for
knight captures an e5 then bishop to f5
with you know
so much pressure the queenside castle is
happening the king is still on d1 you
can't go to e1 it's completely lost for
white uh so instead after d captures an
e3 we have f captures on e3 you have to
play this and now queen to b6 by magnus
now you could capture on e3 because the
bishop here is pinned so here knight to
c3 blocking this bishop and now just the
bishop captures and uh c3 now if bishop
captures we can capture an e3 here so b
captures on c3 and now we have castle's
king side by magnus so now you can see
that white's pawn structure is a bit
ruined and he still needs to throw in
like bishop to e2 and castles the
you know get his king the safety and try
play this uh game so bishop to e2 and
the magnus goes rook to d8 now castling
would be a bit premature maybe the
knights to e4 it's you know it's funny
to say the castle would be premature
because white should have castled a long
time ago although it's uh impossible
here but after 94 it's really really
difficult to withstand all this pressure
for example even the rook to b1 can be
met with the simple rook captures on d2
and now if queen captures we're going to
capture on d2 and now you're down a
queen so you have to recapture but now
knight captures on f3 we grab another
piece with check and after this captures
captures uh we're just up a full piece
so something like this could happen so
instead we have queen to c2 and now
bishop to g4 just uh keeping uh on with
the development and putting pressure on
white's position we have h3 bishop to h5
now going for that bishop to g6 move
that will really put pressure on the
white queen and now king f2 now you are
ready to bring your rook into the game
and hopefully uh maybe even artificially
castle so bishop to g6 attacking the
queen queen to b3 but now knight to e4
with check we have king to e1 and now
even the knight captures on d2 again
making it impossible for queen captures
queen because first we're going to
eliminate one more piece with check and
then we're going to be up a piece if you
guys want to see this uh just knight
captures bishop capture say captures and
we're up a night so instead after knight
captures on d2 we have knight captures
on d2 and now queen captures an e3 now
again threatening queen captures on d2
so knight to f1 attacking the queen
queen g5 and now queen captures on b7
attacking the knight here and uh you
know it's not um
all that easy for
for black to play this but there are
moves that help so here are queen
captures on g2 uh defending the knight
also attacking the rook and h1 so rook
to h2 attacking the queen and queen back
to e4 the only move for black to keep
advantage
as you have to keep an eye on that
knight so knights the d2 attacking the
queen and now you could play a lot of
moves here but magnus just plays the
absolute quickest way uh to victory and
that is uh queen to h4 check now if you
go back then you're going to lose the
knight here so you have to go king to d1
and now we shift the queen back queen to
f4 now we're threatening to win the rook
also we're threatening checkmate here
and of course he was in this position on
mu 24 that andrew tang resigned the game
as there is nothing more uh to be done
here but as this was pretty much
straightforward uh straight out of the
opening after that uh blunder in the
opening i forgot to mention uh knight to
the c3 this is actually this has never
been played before of course because
it's so bad for white uh that it was a
completely new uh game already as of
move five uh in case you guys are
wondering so it's so bad that uh it was
never played before but it was probably
pre-moved so it doesn't really matter
i just used it as an example of what
could happen but since we didn't have a
positive video in this moment everything
was really just you know straightforward
uh what if what if uh andrew just plays
bishop to g4 here and now uh his knight
is nicely defended so now you can
deliver checkmate on d2 what's the
absolute quickest way for white to win
this for black to win this uh well i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not allowing me
to trick you and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show of course it
is mate in one and that is queen to f1
now congratulations to everyone as i
know all of you found this uh
i'm just you know making a little joke
here uh because uh the king is in check
of course we can't go to c2 the bishop
covers that and the knight cannot
capture the queen because the knight is
pinned so that's the that's the good
stuff
uh so yeah uh really interesting stuff
and uh
you know we'll see how long magnus keeps
playing bullet uh will he he will he
keep playing it all the way uh up to the
wheelchairs championship match or is
this maybe the the last we'll see of
magnus before the uh match against nepo
starts uh in dubai uh but it's very
interesting i don't know i i don't think
nepo is uh very much interested in what
magnus is doing but it's kind of you
know it kind of throws in throws out
this vibe that maybe magnus is just you
know completely relaxed he's just you
know having uh you know a nice bath or a
nice you know uh swimming in a pool and
then maybe playing some bullet games
online uh and then you know just
crushing andrew here you know by by
adopting him by winning 10 games in a
row so i don't think it uh interests
nepo at all but uh you know it
i i i i i it would be hard to say that
it
made absolutely zero impression on him
uh so i'm also very interested in what
you guys think is this is this the way
to go is this uh you know a good way to
be spending you know days before the
wheelchair championship match uh you
know yeah
if you have any anything to you know add
on the on the subject feel free to you
know share it in the comment section
below uh so yeah uh that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it thank you for uh
suggesting it as usual you can check uh
all of the games that were played uh you
know just on leeches go on carlson's
profile or on andrew's profile and you
can check out all of the games
i would like to thank lucas de ocardis
james mayberry abdullah throughout frank
combs and david lille for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh the coverage of the grants
with checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day